there are a lot of ways to make money
and animal crossing new horizons but if
you want to maximize profits here are
some tips to make a ton of bells the
most obvious and consistent way to make
money is to catch and sell insects and
fish fishing and bug catching itself is
pretty straightforward but we do have a
few suggestions that can significantly
increase your payout first if you're low
on pocket space and can't go to the
store easily
we recommend releasing any bugs or fish
that aren't worth alot for example if
your ocean fishing it's usually best to
release any sea bass dabs or horse
mackerels you catch as they are only
worth four hundred three hundred and 150
Bells respectively instead you should
try to fill your pockets with red
snappers barred knife jaws or whatever
other rare fish might be in season as
for bug catching you should probably
ignore common butterflies yellow
butterflies and tiger butterflies in
favor of emperor butterflies peacock
butterflies tarantulas and tiger beetles
now keep in mind these insects aren't
available all year so keep an eye out
for high-value fish and bugs as you sell
your catch to the new clings if you're
struggling to find fish you can also dig
up Manila clams on the beach and craft
fish Bay you can use fish bait to spawn
a fish near you once you have a decent
amount of rare fish in your pockets you
can sell them at nooks cranny however
there are two visitors you should look
out for before you sell anything flick
and CJ they buy bugs and fish
respectively for a 50% markup however as
of this recording I've played New
Horizons for almost two weeks and I've
only seen flick once if you want a
detailed list on bug and fish prices
I'll leave a link to a GameSpot story
below one Rock everyday will spew money
when you hit it you need to hit it eight
times in rapid succession to maximize
your reward and because your villager
will recoil when you hit it it's usually
a good idea to dig a few holes behind
you before hitting any rocks so you
don't have to readjust if done correctly
you should walk away with 16100 bells
every day just make sure your shovel is
in tip-top shape because the last thing
you'll want is your shovel breaking
after a couple hits
for the price of mm nope miles you can
visit a random unexplored island there
are a lot of benefits to this but some
of these islands are ripe with
money-making opportunities right off the
bat most of these islands appear to have
higher spawn rates for bugs and fish
however the real reason you should visit
unexplored islands as much as possible
is because you can occasionally stumble
on rare islands you could find an island
covered in money rocks or maybe an
island crawling with tarantulas okay
that last one sounds a bit terrifying
but considering tarantulas are 8,000
ahead you could walk away with a lot of
bells
we recommend emptying your pockets of
everything except the essentials before
you leave for an island so you can carry
as much home with you as possible and
have an even bigger payout I typically
try to visit at least one island a day
but if you have the nook miles there's
nothing stopping you from going multiple
times by traveling to friends and
unexplored islands you may come across
non-native fruit this can be any fruit
of the vine coconuts which sell for 250
apiece and whatever fruit your island
started with you can sell non-native
fruit for 500 bells each or you can
plant it we recommend you do the latter
once the fruit tree grows you'll be able
to sell a lot more foreign fruits on a
consistent basis speaking of trees you
can also bury money in glowing spots
which should sprout money trees there's
one glowing spot per day and no you
can't bury a shovel in it to get a
golden shovel like on GameCube but you
can bury some bells there and the tree
that grows will likely produce bags of
money once when it's grown the stock
market spelled s ta LK is animal
Crossing's stock market every Sunday
Daisy May will come to your Island and
sell you turnips for a fluctuating price
usually somewhere around a hundred bells
for 10 turnips
the idea is to buy turnips from her and
sell them to Timmy and Tommy later in
the week for a higher value the catch is
that turnips will rot after a week Timmy
and Tommy changed their prices every day
when they open and again at noon so you
want to check with them before and after
noon every day to monitor the turnips
value if done correctly you should walk
away with a decent profit
one snooks cranny opens up Timmy and
Tommy will ask for a hot item every day
basically the hot item is something you
can sell to the new clinks for double
the value if you have a ton of extra
wood iron and other crafting materials
you could craft the hot item multiple
times and sell it to them for a much
higher price however before you
mass-produce the hot item I recommend
selling just one and weighing its value
next to the amount of resources you'll
expend sometimes it just isn't worth it
[Music]
if you just picked up animal crossing
new horizons be sure to check out our
day 1 guide and things you should do
every day videos thank you so much for
watching
[Music]